the fact that we're here today it's a
modern miracle no one even wanted the
first one i was the eleventh choice and
I basically had to do a song and dance
to get it distributor Rambo is not a guy
you want to mess with my ego is saying
oh yeah I could take him but my knees
are buckling so ya know the legend and
the man are returning the theaters
here's everything you need to know
before you go
[Applause]
[Applause]
Rambow is a pop culture icon the guy has
been made into action figures slept on
lunchboxes and inspired videogames so
who is he it was always a very remote
character an isolated character kind of
like what he was Sylvester Stallone
first brought Rambo to life in 1982 and
first blood
I see how it's all coming together full
circle first blood two last blood get it
[Music]
John James Rambo fought in the Vietnam
War as a highly skilled member of the US
Army Special Forces when he returned
home he had difficulty readjusting to
civilian life and became a homeless
drifter traveling the country for about
a decade until a fateful run-in with the
law initially to avoid a prison sentence
Rambo was later recruited for various
military operations including one
mission that returned him to Vietnam to
rescue prisoners of war fun fact in 1986
Rambo got his own GI Joe esque animated
series titled Rambo the force of freedom
the cartoon was far from realistic it
infamously had Rambo riding on a missile
in one episode
okay so let's quickly catch you up on
the previous Rambo movies in first blood
Rambo is in search of one of his friends
from his unit but he learns he's died of
cancer making Rambo the sole survivor of
his group the film follows the Vietnam
vet to Washington state where he was
harassed by local small-town authorities
he of course defended himself in the
most extreme of ways
Rambo would have gone to jail had it not
been for his former commanding officer
Colonel Trautman Trotman helped Rambo by
putting the soldier to better use in
service of his country God didn't like
Rambo
I made him in the action packed sequel
Rambo First Blood Part 2 we saw Rambo's
first big mission for Troutman this film
started to lean more into the gore and
violence that the film series is known
for Rambo found love and a fellow
veteran during a mission in Vietnam but
sadly she died suddenly only fueling his
anger more after her death his focus was
to rescue prisoners of war from a camp
in Vietnam as a lone wolf he
single-handedly took out the Vietnamese
and Soviet troops pursuing him and after
defeating his enemies he was awarded a
presidential pardon and decided to
remain in Thailand Rambo 3 kicked off
with Colonel Trautman trying to enlist
his favorite soldier again to go up
against the Russians who were warring
with freedom fighters in Afghanistan
despite seeing the photos of suffering
Afghani civilians John passed on joining
the fight Chapman went to Afghanistan
without Rambo and was captured by the
Russians thus leading to Rambo's arrival
and successful rescue of Troutman flash
forward 20 years and we get to the
number 4 film in the franchise Rambo I
retired John Rambo has been living a
peaceful life on the border of Thailand
and Myanmar his help is requested when a
group of missionaries don't return to
his village he's hesitant again to put
his skills to use but he's just too good
at what he does so of course he Rambo's
up he led a team of mercenaries
alongside the rebel myanmar army who
were against anti democracy government
forces and at the end of the film he
moved back to the States and retired on
a horse farm in Arizona
and to end it all we've come to the
latest film in the franchise Rambo last
blood will learn what John has been up
to in the last ten years since the
fourth film and this is the first time
he gets to go back home to his ranch
live a simple life and then boom oh
she's got come home looks like he's back
to his basics with his bow and arrow and
once again I'm not messing with this guy
and despite the film being in a new
location seems like Rambo last blood
continues the franchise's focus with
Rambo being reluctantly recruited so
much time has passed but we're excited
to see John Rambo back in action looks
like he might have some new methods of
Defence - and to help you out even more
here some killer Rambo facts to discuss
with your friends before the movie
starts
[Music]
so now you know and now you can go see
Rambo last blood in theatres September
20th
[Music]
you